hello everyone and welcome to an amazing
game from the super bed rapid and blitz
tournament vishwanathan versus
kiroshevchenko uh you guys requested
this one pretty much as soon as it ended
this is from the blitz section uh so the
rapid portion ended i believe on the one
with with clear first he lost the final
game to duda but he still uh was in the
lead uh and now we have the uh the blitz
section this is just uh just an amazing
game of course uh the lines will be uh
somewhat crazier as it is to be expected
from blitz uh but uh you know also more
more enjoyable on um
a couple of fronts so here uh we've seen
a game by shivchenko not uh not so long
ago if you remember we've had that in
norway versus ukraine solidarity match
where shivchenko defeated magnus carlsen
so he is uh
an incredibly strong player now let's
dive straight into it uh anand has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 uh c5
chenko goes for the sicilian defense
knight f3 d6 and now bishop to c4 on and
goes for the uh close sicilian for the
moment
knight to f6 d3 and now e6 we have
castles and here uh there are a couple
of moves that are
played here bishop to a7 and knight the
c6 are the most common ones but here we
have g6 this is a new move so already as
of move five we have a completely new
game yeah so let's see how anand deals
with this very early novelty uh he goes
rook to e1 just uh plays as if you were
playing um let's say a joko piano
against the sicilian we have bishop to
g7 c3 uh and then now uh shivchenko
castles with bishop back to b3 and b6
now we have d4 striking in the center uh
and bishop to b7 we have bishop back to
c2 and now knight to c6 putting more
pressure on the d4 square a3 and now
rook to c8 so both players just uh
continuing um at their development uh
it's already move 11 and no pieces or
pawns have been captured yet uh h3 uh we
have queen to c7 developing the queen
connecting rooks bishop to d3 now
and uh pawn to a6 we have bishop to e3
continuing development rook after d8 we
have knight b to d2 and now pawn to b5
and here sherchenko is ready to play c4
and this will not only attack the bishop
but also after c4 is played the pawn on
b2 will remain there pretty much for the
rest of the game it's going to be a
backward spawn and um well maybe even a
a pretty big liability in white's camp
so anand advances the pawn to b4 he
doesn't want to have a backward spawn
and only now c4 we have bishop back to
c2 and a5
uh so okay the center is pretty much
closed okay uh there there's some
dynamics still
to be decided whether the center will be
closed but here black is uh threatening
eight captures on on b4 or maybe he
wants to just close the
close the queen side with the pawn to a4
anand goes knights to f1 he wants to
remaneuver the knight and now rook to a8
and here anand plays rook to c1 which
pretty much means that um black will
very very happily capture on b4 as he
can infiltrate with the rook on a3 then
put the other rook on a8 control the a
file and put fresh on screen side and
here we have the first capture of the
game a captures on b4 it is now on move
19 that our first capture occurs uh a
captures on b4 anand captures back and
now rook to a3 attacking the c3 pawn
that's currently undefended but
unprepared for this he has a rook on c1
so just bash her back to b1 and this
also guards the a2 square so you don't
have to worry about the rook
infiltrating any further into your
position knight to e7 uh opening up the
bishop's diagonal attacking the e4 pawn
and knight the g3 on and nicely defends
we have rook d to a8 uh fully
controlling the a file now and the
f4
very nasty to see move like this
especially in the blitz game so queen to
b6 getting the queen out of harm's way
and queen to d2 developing finally
knight to d7 now opening up this
bishop's diagonal as well and bishop to
g5 now attacking the knight here the
knight is undefended uh and here
shivchenko just kicks the bishop back
with f6 we have bishop to h6 offering a
trade of dark square bishops
and queen to c7 now that the bishop left
the f4 square we have h4 ana wants to
play h5 and must open the king side
knight to f8 we have h5 and here
what do you play well it's a very uh
very tricky position uh black has
pressure on the queen side the center is
still flexible and what is uh what is
happening on the king side uh here
shochenko should play e5 uh this allows
him uh to bring the knight over to e6 it
also closes this bishop's diagonal and
you are asking uh white uh
what are you going to do here if you
play d5 to try and um
prevent my knight from reaching the e6
square and closing the light square
bishop diagonal uh on and can all shift
chances can just bring the bishop to c8
and then re-maneuver it over here so e5
would definitely be a good idea for
black here but he played g5 instead and
here he gives ananda a very very deadly
there and i don't even have to ask you
to pause the video here because i know
you guys uh know very well what anand
played here
uh and that of course is bishop captures
on g7 now you probably were thinking
about knight captures on g5 but if you
if you play this first then bishop
captures on h6 and that's uh that's a
problem sometimes the move order doesn't
really matter all that much if if a line
is forced but if a line isn't forced and
black isn't forced to recapture right
away then you have to be careful what
you play first so here bishop characters
on g7 and now uh on after king captures
on g7 anand goes e5 now uh of course
knight captures and g5 is the strongest
move but this is a blitz game and again
f captures and g5 is not four so if
black doesn't play this then black has
all sorts of variety of moves that black
can play and uh it's uh not easy to find
um a follow-up here for here for white
so instead anand first plays e5 and this
uh
uh well it very much weakens the g5
square next you're threatening e
captures on f6 and then you are busting
through here so shivchenko does pretty
much the only thing he can d captures on
e5 d captures on e5 and now uh bishop
captures an f3 removing one of the
attackers
g captures on f3 and now how do you deal
with this again if you capture then you
allow the queen to infiltrate and the
interesting thing is if you play h6
which kind of seems to close the
position completely this is still deadly
now you have to capture otherwise you're
just going to lose material and after
king captures on f6 queen to d4 with
check and now you don't really have a
good square if you play e5 then you
expose
your position a bit too much and if you
go back then you even allow a move like
queen to queen to h8 so
that that's what would happen if a move
like h6 was played and this is a very
strong uh however uh not uh you know not
not great for blizz game it would be too
passive and you would eventually lose
this so instead f5 was played offering
the g5 pawn this also means that king
the h8 will be played and then the rook
might come to g8 and this could be very
powerful as the white king is also on
the g file so here anand captures queen
captures and g5 would check it's the
only move to continue
uh with advantage uh it requires some uh
some risk but uh you know on a result
for it king the h8 and now rook eat the
d1 here queen to f6 is a bit more
precise but again it's a blitz game uh
anand goes for rook e to d1 we have rook
3 to a6 adding a defender to the to the
sixth rank and also keeping an eye on
that d6 square you know that this rook
is coming to d6 at some point so here we
have f4 adding a defender to the e5 pawn
and knight to g8 now uh we have rook to
d4 and now rook to e8 we have rook c to
d1 now this rook definitely is coming to
d6 and rook to e7 uh and now of course
you do not want to see rook the g7 on
the board so h6 we prevented this uh
rook the a8 and now finally rook to d6
we have rook 8 the e8 and look at
black's pieces now the rooks are doubled
up on the e7 uh on the e file uh to keep
an eye on the e6 pawn the knights are on
f8 and g8 to the queen not really doing
all that much here but still even though
it's a very passive position how do you
how do you actually break through well
there are a couple of options you could
play you could improve your position
slightly you could go knight to h5 but
ananda just goes straight for the kill
he plays bishop characters on f5 and now
you see that well even without
calculating you will have two connected
past pawns and in the beautiful attack
so here e captures on f5 there is
nothing better knight captures on f5 and
now uh knight the g6 uh interestingly uh
if you play rook to f7 okay you don't
have to give up the rook but if you try
to move the rook let's say rook to f7
then anand has this queen g7 a beautiful
temporary queen sacrifice and after rook
captures h captures on g7 check forces
the queen to recapture queen captures
knight captures and after king captures
you again have this position where two
rooks will uh
fight against the rook and two knights
but still it's two connected past pawns
this is completely winning for white
so after knight captures on f5 jochenko
tries knights to g6 this is the the last
attempt pretty much uh but now anand
just uh goes for the rook knight
captures on e7 rook captures on e7 and
rook to d8 now uh we have rook to f7 uh
putting pressure on the f4 pawn but now
pawn to e6 attacking the rook and now
again if you move the rook rook to a7
then we have queen to f6 check and there
is no move you have to bring the rook to
g7 to block this and now even rook one
to d7 and next move will be checkmate of
course the knight cannot capture the the
knight is pin so there is no move here
for black so beautiful beautiful
attacking potential and and any position
can be played in so many ways that uh
it's even it's impossible for me to even
make a pause the video moment of this
game there's just uh too many great
lines uh so here rook captures an f4 was
played but of course this doesn't help
rook one to d7 queen to c6 and now uh on
and again has so many ways to finish the
game he decides to sacrifice the queen
uh why not go out uh you know in great
style uh but just for fun i will show
that pretty much anything he's winning
here rook capture sanji 8 also a
beautiful line king captures now rook to
d8 to check rook to f8 and now it's a
very nice rook captures king captures
and queen to d8 to check with the pawns
guarding the f7 and g7 squares there's
not much for the king to do here king
queen will block queen to f6 with check
now you either block and get checkmated
on f7 or you move the king and get
checkmated on g7 not much of an option
but those are your options so here uh
queen captures an f4 was played on and
decides to end the game this way uh we
have knight captures and now rook
captures and g8 with check and he was in
this position on mu 47 that kirito
shivchenko resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here of
course once the rook is captured and
this is the only move the pawns again
cover the f7 and g7 squares and of
course rook to d8 will be checkmate
once the black queen blocks check and
now rook the e8 will be checkmate so
another brilliant game by by anand in in
great attacking style and
you can see how how it all came down to
this uh moment it was a very exciting
game i mean 20 moves without without a
capture that's uh that's really really
really awesome uh here it's it's a
really crazy position and i mean any
pawn move can be a great move you know
maybe something with the rook maybe
maybe uh there there are so many options
here but what to do that's that's the
real question however g5 just allowed on
us to completely blast through the
position and create another masterpiece
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it thank you for suggesting
it as usual i would like to thank uh
david kimura adam simmons robert kiefer
mark manner and nagarjuna ponogoti for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world yeah so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day